it's a question we get all the time in
the YouTube comments how do i layer up
for winter today we're going to answer
for winter you're going to need a winter
coat two winter coats it's okay if you
have five or seven or three but you need
at least two the obvious thing to do is
when you got on jeans and a sweater you
wear the parka and when you've got on a
suit you are the top coat but the thing
we've been showing in GQ and the thing I
myself like to do is flip it up you wear
the parka on really cold days over a
suit and you take a really nice
tailored top coat and you use it to
dress it up your jeans give it a try
another key to layering up for winter
right now is invest in a vest when it
comes to quilted vests one cool thing
you can do is wear it under your suit
jacket almost like a three-piece suit
when it comes to puffers there's a
little twist we at GQ like to put on it
or you take a puffer vest and put it
over a suit jacket of course you can
also wear it over jeans under a parka
however you want to roll guys it's not
the 1970s anymore but the turtleneck is
back in a big way and it looks damn good
you can wear it more in a casual way
Steph Curry's got it with a suede jacket
or you can sort of dress it up a little
like Tom Brady ditch the shirt and tie
even if it seems a little intimidating
at first if you get a turtleneck I
promise you're gonna find yourself
wearing it at least once a week another
really cool trick to winter layering is
after you put on your shirt and tie
don't immediately reach for your suit
jacket put on a hoodie like Cam Newton
here or a big heavy fisherman sweater
like Norman Reedus you're going to be
dressed up you're also going to be warm
and it's going to be a good look once
you get those four steps down it's time
to get a little bit advanced and
whenever we're talking about advance
style you could look to Kanye West first
he puts on a long t-shirt then he puts
on a kinda long sweater and then he puts
on a short bomber jacket so everything's
sort of inside out it might sound
complicated and it definitely looks
really cool and kind of complicated but
the fact of the matter is it's actually
pretty easy to do long less long short
and you're done guys when we tell you at
the end of all these videos that if you
leave a question in the comment section
we'll answer it this is living proof so
fire away and thank you
Oh